oh you can perfect
[Music]
perfect
what's up everybody I'm Thomas dobiziola
whatever you want to call me this is my
co-host Marty O'Neal what the [__] is up
folks what's up special starting it up
so today folks starting it off all right
let's go guys we've been talking about
since season one it's finally here this
is the Benny The Butcher episode thank
you for being here the butcher coming
man what's up with you thank you man and
we're just gonna start it up this is
cereal milk I light that one up
cereal milk let's go look at this [__]
you got a lighter right next to you too
I do and I do you gotta at the Astro
all right y'all if y'all could see this
[__] at home
little little
3.5s oh that's what this is yeah they're
like oh about four grams ish make sure I
got my inhaler in my pocket
yeah hold on does the inhaler
intentionally match the outfit or is
that a coincidence
all right oh before we start I don't got
nodes and [__] the Pink Floyd shirt sir
what's up dude you do are you a Pink
Floyd fat you know what I'm not gonna
say I'm not a I'm not a I'm not into the
the Pink Floyd but people may think I am
from the shirt but I'm definitely into
this type of fashion [__] got you got
these with these guys did with these
shirts it's the same thing we trying to
recreate now as artists and you can see
everybody copying them right now so
definitely had a rocket here it's what's
crazy it's 500 shirt I'm pretty sure yes
I'm pretty sure it was a 500 when Pink
Floyd put these [__] out this is from
Max Fields wait it's like a what's brand
it's just a Pink Floyd shirt for 500 yes
why
I have no idea back when they're on tour
in the 70s and 80s all those shirts were
coming out of New Buffalo shirt factory
his cousins
invented [__] they were doing pretty
uh Super Bowl they were doing the Jordan
Pippin shirts they were doing Garth
Brooks Pink Floyd all that shirt oh
that's crazy you know uh Ad Pro and
buffalo they do a lot of they do a lot
of uh NFL jerseys because cause it's
Terry pagula and he owns the company he
owns the bills so they do NFL jerseys
they do hockey jerseys damn NHL they do
NBA jerseys a lot of [__] getting made
right in Buffalo not to mention
[__] New Era headquarters right
now this is it yeah headquarters in
Buffalo New York downtown that's why you
got all these [__] Fitness Marty no
this is for real I never met nobody that
changes their hats all the time like I
went in at her shop the other day I went
in there and I just got my hats and then
they just bag my hats up and I'm like I
didn't pay and they was like man you're
good everything is what I'm saying right
right in your own City that shit's hard
all Buffalo knowledge and history I know
because of this dude right here this
whole show is about it's all obscure
it's the only way I mean I only know
about [__] because from Buffalo because
of you and about four years ago my homie
put me on he's like you check out
Griselda I'm from New York from New York
all right cool brought it up to Marty
goes stop what you're doing that was a
season one bro you've been on that
soundboard since season [__] one
it's a trip yeah we got the whole
Griselda mix on here for all different
kinds of reactions
situations I think you pulled one on Dr
Drew too yeah we get people tripping
balls on [__] shrooms in here and
shuts yeah with the soundboard but
that's fire but thank you for being here
man I really appreciate I know you're
busy and you're going back on tomorrow
uh I might say an extra couple days oh
okay I'm out here having fun I'm working
getting [__] done so I love it man about
to embark on a world tour correct uh I I
just came off when I'm booking dates
right now and they might add some role
or they might add some uh some dates in
Europe in there but yeah I was in this
chair oh [__] I'm definitely putting
together some uh some tour dates but yo
I went when I did go overseas that [__]
was the craziest [__] [__] ever like
in what way it well to me
this is like one of the things that I
noticed when I do a show I'm like when I
say Benny y'all say the butcher I'm like
Benny they like the butcher
it's like it's that they're so in tune
and in that moment I realized like they
don't even speak this English
they don't even speak when I [__]
speak and they just hear just rocking
out and I had to like
just a whole bunch of dope experiences
out there man I love it the fans and it
just it's just it's just more in tune
with the fans just more attuned maybe
because they don't get a chance to see
[__] like that I don't think so
so I think it has to be why because you
can't miss the show if you hear if
you're in Buffalo Benny's playing like
[__] I'm working I'll catch the next one
but you're in
we've had a lot of artists tell us that
Europe is a way more uh not supportive
but like you said more in tune yeah
um but I know you got Marty brought it
up this morning you got a new project
coming out a new thing you just kind of
everybody can't go man that's the new
album I'm saying shout out Rock Nation
shout out devjam uh shout out to Black
soprano family shout out Griselda
it's just that you know I'm at this
point that everybody can't [__] go
and I had to name the album after that
but yeah I was shooting a video
yesterday I was on the [__] crane yep
[__] I saw the scissor lifting right
right at first what the [__] dude what
am I doing right
you dropped such a mass amount of Music
how long has this project been in the
works for
I would say since I signed a Dev gym
album Maybe
a year
but uh they don't take me a year to make
a project it takes me a year to to get
comfortable to want to release a project
I could drop projects every [__] one
of my one so I got like 200 unreleased
songs Jesus some
some that I recorded last week and some
[__] that I recorded
three three years ago but it's just that
the fans when I when I put a project out
I started my career like this when I
dropped
uh Tana talk three that was my intro
album uh as a Brazil the artist when I
dropped that [__]
I moved to I moved to Atlanta to work on
it with Wes in February it was done by
March I had an April [__] right I had an
April release release date for it but
things started picking up so fast we
just slowed down and started working on
different [__] and it was 18 months from
when I first started working on it to to
when I released it when it was actually
ready like in two months but
when you make people not make people but
when the people are starving for the
project when they want it because a lot
of dudes put music out but nobody's
looking for the music you're putting out
nobody nobody asks for that album yeah
you know what I'm saying nobody asked
for that [__] so
putting out albums when fans are asking
for them and supporters are asking for
them that's a totally different thing
they ready for the [__] the best problem
to have right right right yeah because
you see artists with huge backing on
giant labels selling for 40 tickets no
one showing to the [__] show it's a
it's a like we said before you can have
a million followers and not pack a
basement real [__] real [__] it's scary
to look at honestly yeah it's kind of a
facade like who's real out here yeah
because
I'm going to cut you off but you got
different type of fans right
some fames all they will do is troll for
you 100 all they all they gonna do is
say under my if I put up a post and say
like yo [__] can't [__] with me I'm
really like that they might tag well
this artist is doing that but that's all
that artist is going that's all that fan
is going to do for you this [__] not
gonna buy a ticket not gonna buy a hat
not gonna buy your shirt they just gonna
Troll and tag your name you know what
I'm saying they're not even they're
going to stream the music they're not
even going to [__] buy it off uh
Apple they're not even gonna buy it off
title they're not going to do none of
that [__] so it's just like you got to
be careful It's Tricky you know what I'm
saying don't let these people don't let
these fans
like big your [__] head up to like
you know I'm saying like you [__]
Michael Jackson the [__] Jack who
stole somebody damn shakers did you
notice your fan base change uh when you
signed the deal because to me you always
had such like a die-hard like cult
following core fan base before the deal
was it like all you felt the difference
from all these new people coming around
in terms of your fan base and your pages
and show honestly honestly
yes and no yes because I see the new the
new uh the new Fanfare the new you know
the followers whatever but I don't call
them people fans you know they're just
Spectators they just watch you know this
guy signed the dev jam oh he's a rapper
they don't even know who the [__] I am
Spectators you know what I'm saying so
the fans the number one fans are still
there The Spectators some of them I'm a
converter fans and I'm saying there's
other people it's people right now who
never [__] heard of me who want to
hear that album and I'm gonna convert
them to fans so you know and this game
[__] tricky what I tell people man A
lot of times you Gotta Throw
you got to throw your best punch first
meaning you you might not knock the
[__] out if you're a boxer you
might not knock them out with your
hardest punch you probably woke him up
two rounds ago with that punch and broke
him down so it might take a little
lighter punch to put him down so it's
like when you get in this game
a lot of a lot of you she got to shoot
your [__] off early your best [__] off
early me I'm far from done I'm far from
shooting my best [__] off and I'm saying
I got at least if you ask me I got 10
more years in this [__] at least but
it's like
you can't be holding on to no [__] no
say okay
you're describing do you see the style
Bender fight last week I've seen that
you're describing that fight with this
whole mentality yeah you're right throw
your best [__] punch first throw that
best punch first man but at what level
were you at before the deal after the
deal where you realize like damn I'm one
of the elite rappers alive Jadakiss push
it put me on a track with anybody I'm up
there mm-hmm uh well let me say that I
mean the answer to answer your question
let me answer that in a second but I
would just watch somebody sent me this
uh
Miss Diddy sent me this actually she was
like yo that's crazy [__] Big Daddy
Kane
was on the drink Champs interview saying
like yo J Cole he's he's that guy he
said I love Benny The Butcher he's like
I love Conway and I love Benny The
Butcher but Cole is that guy and it's
like damn me I'm still humble
so it was like damn
I ain't even know who the Kane who the
[__] I was you know what I'm saying so
it was like and him when he was doing
his [__] he was considered that guy yeah
yeah so it was like he's comparing me to
those guys Conway is that guy yeah for
sure uh J Cole is definitely that guy
yeah and I'm saying and it's like to be
compared with those guys that let me
know now I'm a top lyrics is when it
comes from Top guys who are top Lyricist
yes not when it comes from you know like
Ralph who's sitting on the couch and
[__] not saying that his opinion doesn't
matter but it doesn't matter as much as
[__] big daddy Kane's but
uh
when as an artist when you you know you
rising and [__] and the game is when
your career and your lifestyle affects
other people's lifestyle when when my
mom is start getting free [__] and my
daughters tell it my daughter's telling
me about their experiences right you
know this [__] just don't only affect me
you know you know what I'm saying this
is like people who people who never who
I never even posted with you know they
they got the little
uh they got the little magnitude of Fame
I'm saying that shit's just dope so
that's when I knew before they do I knew
just running around being having a
connection with Eminem you got to remind
you we came in a game like that yeah
that's [__] no I'm saying I was kind
of out of nowhere like to me too [__]
you know but that's when it seemed like
after that happened then it's like okay
now it's features with Wu-Tang now like
now Legends are starting to really like
pay their respects and you guys had
organically grown and it wasn't some
overnight [__] so they were like yeah of
course let them in they belong to me let
them in let them in you know I mean and
that's when I knew like being around him
and and kicking it with Hove and
you know when when you when you get
coached when you get coached by the by
the old players it's like I'm pretty
sure when you see Braun walking off the
court and then he's stopping and he's
kicking it with Bill Russell yeah the
dream I'm pretty sure to him I gotta
feel like damn that was the dream right
there that's the reason why we do this
[__] yeah we wouldn't have thought about
doing this [__] if it wasn't for these
guys and you had those moments with
Jay-z Eminem they're sitting down
dropping knowledge on you and check
definitely hold Raekwon uh kiss
everybody from the locks Royce of course
Emery you're not a rapper but e
uh man it's crazy that I'm not thinking
of these guys right now because he wrote
this big ass blunt for me there's so
many right yeah but there's so many
dudes and Lil Wayne and I was just
thinking about this the other day
it's that
those guys get it you feel me to
understand that outside of the money
outside of the the the the women and
outside of the [__] Fame outside of
the material things they understand that
my position is to somewhat to somewhat
guide the Next Generation in the right
direction even if that comes with
encouragement you know how far that go
if if one of the great said you a good
job and I go I go a long way man come on
and and I'm pretty sure a lot of the
guys I named
know that yeah J Cole too he's been in
this game for a long time you know I'm
saying that's my homie too we kick it
all the time so code to uh man that's a
whole bunch of duels I'm gonna name this
guys who not rappers man uh shout out
Mack Mane you know what I'm saying I
take game from anybody man yeah her
generation grew up on the wisdom of
these rappers I don't know Jadakiss
buyers we if you didn't have people
teaching you this [__] you learned
integrity and how to move how to boss
how to be a boss like all that [__]
that's taught us everything that's what
your music is for I know for me for that
whole Next Generation that's what we
hope our podcast is that's the whole
point it's free [__] game free
[__] game all the time because why
wouldn't you you got to be a hated
[__] tonight you gotta be a
hater listen this people who I've met
along my travels
who particularly don't
you know fit my character but I can see
that they're winning so I'm like this
guy got something to say let me see he
knows something that I don't [__]
know it's not about if we if if I like
how he dressed or if I like his
if he vegan or not or you know heavy
black [__] white green blue pearl
don't matter that it's like man this
this [__] guy know what he's talking
about and you would be a hater
[__] or fool just do not want to
kick it and get free game you know what
I mean I think that's the most valuable
thing in the world growing up with the
old my grandpa my like the older I don't
know about you but did you grow up 12
you hang out with all the 16 year olds
and [__]
yeah that's how I feel like I learned so
much Westside Gunner machine gun Black
machine gun Black is my brother West
Side gun is my older cousin I'm not
those guys age a few years older than me
oh they are I was uh
I was the kid when they was running
outside to go play
my mom or west Mama tell them like yeah
take him too oh right I'm not old enough
to do this [__] they about to be jumping
off trees playing tackle football or
maybe with some girls in the
neighborhood I'm not even old enough for
that [__] yet yeah but I'm learning by
default so that saved my life just just
talking about getting game and [__] like
a Westside gun you know what I'm saying
like look at him in the game look what
he's doing curate curating from Fashion
to music to art movies nobody ever liked
him before I don't want to spoil it but
you guys this movie you guys did I'm
gonna say my favorite thing ever is I
don't want to spoil it but after it's
like yo let me get let me buy that I
called this [__] immediately
like that's how you do it you end it
like let me buy a 50 Cent not real [__]
that was that was cold hardest [__] that
was cold blooded I was going crazy
watching that [__] movie
Paris that [__] was [__] crazy yeah
you see me I was in a piece yeah [__]
it's crazy dude and and that's all
independent and that's why you guys are
doing it's
okay look at remember remember
underground like Mac Dre was underground
right for social media he's underground
three more years he would have been
at the independent major because I feel
like you guys are not underground you
don't gotta like you don't you know who
made The Butchers like yeah it's not one
of those oh you gotta you gotta hear
this it's from common knowledge yeah
it's common knowledge but you guys
aren't pushed on MTV and you know what I
mean exactly that's the thing it's a
that's how you sell I think that's how
people solidify themselves in music
is the real hardcore heads that are
listening are gonna go no no [__] that
commercial ass [__] listen to this phone
give me a year I guarantee you exactly
exactly that's that's how that's just
how it works and I think that's why
other artists like you said like the
older dudes are looking at you like no
no that's definitely going to be soon
right and they know and it feels good
when you do it and a year later comes
and you and you
this is this is this is why this is why
my fans and supporters love me because
because I came up like that word of
mouth everybody I meet everybody who
listens Men Let me just thank all the
fans and everybody who [__] with Benny
The Butcher cause y'all always tell me
like yo I'm telling everybody about you
I tell everybody about you and I helped
that argument when they tell you yo
watch about a year like that year come
and I did what they say I was gonna do
and I'm saying so I'm gonna keep
fighting for y'all so keep telling
people good [__] yeah no he was he like
I told him when I when I brought it up
my Griselda goes oh hold on they're from
Buffalo and then he just sat me down and
heard and then that's when we started
the podcast stand down real [__] yeah
can I tell you the first time I ever
heard about you what's that so I was
playing basketball at Damon so I'm on my
back I just went there with Don Juan
Tyson Juan Stroud Jeremy yeah make sure
y'all listen to this story right here
right it was legendary basketball I
didn't realize when I went to Damon oh
this is like the best hoopers in the
town are up here for the summer league
and [__] so I played a season at Damon
and then I went to madai I'm like all
right I'm not getting any playing time
I'm gonna go down to madai and dominate
basically I went down to Media did
spring training camp running around
Delaware Park medicine ball all this
crazy [__] got caught up smoking weed
and [__] [__] it off basically got
kicked off the team but in that same
moment I had found music like I had
switched obsessions into music I started
wrapping my [__] ass off as soon as I
did
I got up at deep thinker records I don't
know if you remember that of course I
did them black rock of course I do right
up where I was that's where I was born
Grant and Amherst and she threw it up
there so I got an internship up in a
deep thinker records and I was in there
working on the computer and [__] and the
dude next to me is like 10 to talk this
[__] calling this [__] Ted Talk
and I thought it was like Scarface Tana
I didn't realize then come to find out
oh no no completely different [__]
thing and then I looked into it and then
I because I had an adopted brother and
he was from Wyoming and [__] over there
and like I had I hadn't like I didn't
grow up over there but I was right right
right so it was just from that point on
I've been [__] following right that's
dope that's dope Tina talk in the
beginning you know what I'm saying
that's old 405 so I'm imagining that's
number one right here that's number
that's actually that's number two
no that's 045 that's [__] number one
yeah see he's not talking about two he's
not talking about three that's why I
said make sure y'all listen to the story
a buffalo native no I've been doing this
[__] you know I'm saying heavy and the
point the real underlying point of that
is you know people will look at you and
be like hey you blew up when Eminem came
around they're like like that's when it
started the [__] we're talking about 20
years ago that [__] kicked off when God
knows that's when you put out your first
shot right right I tell everybody when I
put out 10 and talking one took over the
city no I took over my block when I put
out 10 to talk two took over the city
I'm saying put out 10 to talk three I
took over like the underground [__]
Griselda Empire put out Tanner talk four
got a gold record you know what I'm
saying it's steps so you know Tana talk
five is going to be crazy
hey what's up guys taking a moment to
talk about one of our sponsors and this
is my bookie for all you Sports betters
out there for all you fans all you
college football and NFL football fans
get ready my bookies offering a huge
deal for all of our fans here at dope as
usual podcast no matter where you're
watching click the link in the
description the my bookie link check out
use our code dope as usual if you spend
fifty dollars you get an automatic 200
free dollars bonus cash yes 50 gets you
200 free bonus cash but you have to use
our code dope as usual Aaron Rodgers may
be out the season may be over but your
season has just begun same day parlays
daily odds and boosts this whole season
with my bookie take advantage right now
you got 50 bucks and you like betting
and you like football get 200 free extra
dollars instantly the second you bet
your first 50 you get it credited right
to your account use our code dope as
usual bet 50 bucks get 200 free go bet
on the games this weekend guys if you're
gonna bet bet with my bookie you could
do any sport but right now it's NFL
season guys it just started we got
football for another four months fifty
dollars gets you 200 free automatically
credited to your account thank you so
much for supporting the brands that
support us back to the episode
hey what's up guys taking a moment to
talk about one of our sponsors and this
is hellofresh for everyone out there
that is on the go whether you have kids
whether you have multiple businesses or
you're just super busy or you're a
procrastinator that's me I'll go grocery
shopping and go hey man I got stuff to
do let me start cooking now and I'll
forget I'll take too long and then I
order out hellofresh has eliminated that
problem from everyone's life right now
you get pre-cut pre-portioned
ingredients recipes all the thinking
that goes into the hard part of cooking
is done everything comes pre-cut the
recipe is ready to go your meals are
prepped all you do is cook it so right
now if you want to take control of your
eating habits and you want to get on a
routine join hellofresh and if you're
watching this and you want to take
advantage of this get 50 yes five zero
use our code hellofresh.com use our code
50 Yola yes 50 Yola use that code at
checkout and you will get 50 off your
first order and then for the next two
months of you reading up and get 15 off
of the next two months there's no
grocery shopping it cuts off the price
of eating out hellofresh is saving you
money time and headache expedite dinner
with hellofresh America's number one
meal kit thank you for supporting the
brand that support us back to the
episode
we saw now you just kind of like at a
show I saw a clip of a new track with
you and Lil Wayne
and we saw a little BTS shot at you with
the [__] video that [__] was in New
Orleans the Buffalo I went crazy when I
heard that right what was that like man
that's that's dope to get the uh
to get to have records like that get to
play them for the city but they're
definitely unreleased big dogs man me
and Wayne Me In Tune it's going crazy
you know I like it's crazy I like to
[__] with all of the greats that's
mandatory that I do that each album I I
got a great Lyricist on there how often
are you guys actually in the studio
together or is it all just email back
and forth and [__] it's just all email
and [__] I'm a buffalo [__] I'm in
Atlanta running around tune out here
somewhere all over yeah I'm saying but I
could listen you know a [__] like him
I would have to say I'm just imagining I
feel like he recorded a lot of that [__]
by himself for sure you have to yeah on
the tour bus and shut up exactly and
that's what I heard too that's what when
I got my first bag that's what they say
like yo he's on tour so he can do it a
lot of times they'd be like I'm on tour
I can't do it
no he's got it in his bus exactly what
they said he's on tour now so it's a
good time I'm like oh [__] oh he's got
down time he got down gotcha because he
got this he got the in the bus so yeah
it's a good time how is it for you does
the writing come in waves when you know
you got a project or is it always or is
it when you're on the tour bus or like
is there Comes In Waves it comes in
waves like you said 20 years ago right
I've been doing this [__] for so long
and basically that made me a legend in
the city putting that album out that
Tina talk one because that was my first
time curating uh I recorded I recorded a
lot of those songs myself like press and
record like I press it then I go in the
booth and I rap it that's how I did Tana
talk one I had my own studio and
everything so it's like
I've been doing this [__] for so long
that it has to come to me that I can't
chase it down I got to be like in a club
chilling buying [__] shopping for two
weeks traveling living my life then I
might just walk out the club
[__] three in the morning like
I got it yeah Eureka you gotta like it's
from experience like no I gotta do some
more cool ass [__] for a minute I gotta
do some [__] yeah I have to because if
not you're reaching and going like what
else have I done before no really talked
about that yeah yeah I have to and just
some special [__] to me talking about
Studios I recorded all the studios in
Buffalo I see when you guys post up a
lot of times the studios I used to
record at uh I put my I put out a
mixtape in o5 called whatever it takes
hosted by Capone from Capone Noriega
printed up 5 000 copies went down to the
city brought it back did the same [__]
went up to Doris Records record theater
really got them all off that's the
Buffalo roll out right yeah all that uh
Consignment deals and [__] but I was in
like uh deep thinker uh Outer Limits I
ended up at I was recording my man T-man
over on Hagen and [__] in his closet for
a long time
Anthony Huff sound like tea Fergus
little brother raps okay okay yeah
definitely you know about otter lemon
I've been that's been a lot of uh
sleepless nights out of yeah can't smoke
in there yeah no all right he wouldn't
let Eminem smoke in there
my boys [__] breaking down the Dutch
and [__] he's like you know I told
Eminem he can't smoke in here
I love that someone else finally knows
what Marty I've been sitting here for
three years listen to these stories bro
I've never met anybody else from from
over there I feel like I could walk the
whole city and know where I'm at just
based on this one right here real [__]
man that's dope man you gotta you gotta
bring them to the city man yeah I will I
will I was supposed to go to New York
yesterday but I I ended up coming here
but yeah totally different from like the
boroughs yeah oh that's what he told me
he's well we brought up Larry lot and
I'm like he's from Buffalo different
[__] country because he's like some
the biggest jewel thief in history we
had him on the show and he got so
[__] crazy stories I bet he do like
damn he like the cat burglar type [__]
no he's like full that bus into your
face
GTA Heist comes in takes it all biggest
jewel thief in American history bro
anyway he talks about I brought up New
York he's like it's not the same country
Buffalo is different yeah that's what I
hear well when Young Jeezy came up here
he was like oh [__] buffalo like
at crazy two million people and not that
long ago million yeah it's probably like
150k now why why hold on how what the
[__] happened it's almost a court it's
still like almost a quarter quarter
million people there how many people why
do people leave what the [__] uh well a
lot of people came to Buffalo a lot of
people came to Buffalo for the steel
industry
uh and and for uh
when the steel industry came out it was
uh like project housing you know those
started off as like good homes they
didn't start off the projects didn't
start off being a [__] projects it
was nice oh [__] exactly it was nice for
real you know what I'm saying in any
project in America you know what I'm
saying to start off as affordable home
for for lower income based people so
you're right I lived in that [__] too
and now it's ghetto as [__] where it is
nice even even where I stayed in the
projects it was ghetto then but it's
more ghetto now but uh
so a lot of people came up there for
jobs for the steel industry and uh
the Erie Canal in 1920 Buffalo this is
like 100 this is less than 100 years
this is 100 years ago 100 maybe 103
years ago in 1920 Buffalo uh spawned the
most millionaires in the country the
most millionaires was made in Buffalo
it's right on the Roosevelt uh with
Detroit Cleveland uh you know just all
of them being close to Canada I'm saying
so it was a spot but you know
technology you know I'm saying goes
forward and you know you got you got
places like [__] Silicon Valley yeah
you know what I'm saying you know when
he says the stealing like I'm from
Lackawanna so like okay we're covered in
[__] from the steel from the steel
spot uh and the [__] is like I always
described as [__] haunted like stay
out right because
they're still there you're like passing
all the old factories and [__] they're
still there yeah because Buffalo seems
like a small town the way you guys talk
about it but
250 is not that small it's the second
biggest city in New York to New York
yeah but I don't know nothing about
geography I'm lost it is it is I never
traveled anywhere that we was illegal
because it's just a hell of packs when I
was younger and I'm gonna bring we where
I'm going and I
I'm sure you've done trips and [__] like
that's the dumbest thing
the worst thing in the world is knowing
you're going to jail and you could have
prevented the [__] that's the worst it's
the worst thing
it is as it's happy you see the lights
like
kind of just rewind just give me one
[__] chance to rewind I would have
left this [__] at home oh [__] but
people from California
and uh Miami in New York City
and
a lot of cities in Texas too it's like
life is kind of different like from you
guys because it's like other [__] going
on in the middle of America that y'all
never used to right that y'all never
could [__] get used to and it's
really like
like large cities in America is only
like 20 of them the rest of the Cities
the other
couple hundred cities is like Middle
America Buffalo I never traveled what
I'm saying uh some City like Milwaukee
uh [__] you know just a regular
cities it's real easy when you're in one
of those cities for it to seem like it's
like the center of the universe that's
what I remember thinking like damn small
town [__] matter so much that's
another thing about the small towns
you're right people people
it's nothing to do there but they love
to have kids exactly but the [__] that
you do
but the [__] that does go on there they
confuse that with [__] to do like it
might be right damn that should be the
[__] slogan of my town bro [__] it
might be it might be a [__] ass
nightclub everybody go to they might
think that's the [__] that there's
nothing to do so this is the [__] to do
but really if you was in a town where it
was [__] to do you wouldn't even think
about that [__] perspective craziest
yeah no it is when I moved out I'm from
a small ass town in the middle of
California it's just drugs gangs and
then agriculture that's the whole town
right so when I came here I realized
like
[__] you can make a lot of money when
you leave home real [__] make a lot of
money when you expand because I was
nervous to move out here triple my
[__] rant for my little ass house
over there but I feel like when you
almost challenge yourself to like all
right I gotta put up 250. I only got
210.
all right I'm gonna go get it tomorrow
but if you didn't care it would have
took you six months to maybe get that
other phone no real [__] people right
they have anything worth having you got
to work you got to work hard I've seen
what kind of car you I've seen what kind
of whip you got right
and I can see your watch you know what
that tell me like I knew you was [__]
[__] up dead broke somewhere before
yeah anybody I met from from having this
money and being having this lifestyle
everybody I met who's rich and [__] they
got a [__] up backstory like yo I
slept in my car oh yeah roaches and rats
before like I learned that that's damn
near part of the story for people like
us who come from where we come from
[__] like us it was doing our mixtapes
doing our rap [__] grinding just you
know whatever trying to find our Niche
that's part of the story so I tell
people when artists come around me and
they be broken [__] up but they'd be
shy I'll be like no come on that's part
of the story that's the first part come
on let's go like that you doing right so
far you know what I mean that's part of
this [__]
that's the way you can put that right
there yeah that's Ted talk [__] right
there true story though because I feel
like that's true I just when you said
that I just started thinking of every
one of my close homies that's doing
great every one of them slept in
someone's house broke as [__] oh no no
it's like your name bro what are you
talking about right I I didn't know what
it meant every time we were at the
grocery store my mom's like I'm
unloading the stuff onto this belt she's
like wait in the car for me every time I
didn't realize that she was like I'm
paying with food stamps I'm kind of
embarrassed can you please go outside I
didn't know that should tell I was like
11 when she just like let me stay one
day I'm like that's why you always send
me the [__] that's why my mom worked her
[__] ass off and she hated taking
[__] help but right right right I
mean bro we're [__] poor what are we
gonna do what are we gonna do you know
I'm saying that's part of the story and
man I love our I I love I love the moms
man because because they sacrificed so
much [__]
and for us to be at a point to help them
you know what I'm saying you know
that's that's the blessings and their
prayers given off you know what I'm
saying so gotta love the mothers man was
your mother supportive of music
my mother damn there was the reason your
mother she had called me downstairs I'm
like your video on watch your video [__]
yeah I'm saying it's like some of them
was my video someone was like man it's
yo [__] you got me come you called me
down here to watch this [__] but my mom
definitely encouraged me to get in this
[__] my mom encouraged me to do
everything I sold drugs with my mother
oh damn you know what I'm saying she
encouraged me to do everything but uh
hip-hop was definitely first and one of
them and I mean it's always encouraged
me she came overseas with me I mean real
[__] so you come to the show she come to
the parties and [__] he's from your spot
we're actual fans I even said the other
day like I think Betty might have took
and Jack a spot for me and I said it the
other day and I'm a [__] hardcore fan
of the jacket that's my that's my [__]
because when it comes to gangster rap or
like street rap that's lyrical it's real
hard to to find other names it's real
it's getting real [__] hard right now
getting real hard it's getting hard to
go who else that's why me I learned I've
been in a car ride and listening to old
[__] because it's hard to find new [__]
that's Marty's life right there yeah
well one of my questions I had was like
if you had a lifetime most listened to
east west south rappers what's the top
three look like
uh East holes
like witch house
a hot witch Hove I would have to say I
would have to say
in my lifetime
volume three I haven't listened to
volume three a lot volume three he he
had he had tasted the big succession and
understood that it wasn't good I'm
saying how you start he had the song
Come and Get me what I'm saying so he
was like I mean he was like [__] the
magazines [__] everybody at that point
you know what I'm saying so it wasn't it
was all the way all the way on to come
up but he had came up went four times
Platinum he was like man this [__] ain't
[__] ain't nothing you know what I'm
saying yeah so that whole West Coast
West Coast
the dog man
gotta go to dog
you know I mean like even
just the career span so long the
influence
you know I mean and uh he just been in
this he's I've been like I said I've
been listening to a lot of old [__]
listen to the doggy style album man you
know what I mean just he was he made you
sing along with his lyrics he was
creative you know what I'm saying he was
he was one of a kind when he hit for
sure so the dog and he went on Joe Rogan
and said
told the world about banning The Butcher
and how he likes helped out the defense
and Shout out yeah shout out to dog man
and and for the South
face Scarface Scarface gotta go Scarface
it's a good three right there that's a
good three now I got a whole a whole
time I'm thinking of these names I got a
bunch of honorable mentions of course
yeah I could have said one or the other
but those that's why I don't say
favorite I say most listened to yup yup
yup most listened to you know that's
actually back to go listen back to all
of the Scarface [__] like I said I've
been listening to the uh Sloop [__]
lately and always go to always go to
hold when I when I wear out when I wear
out [__] hard knock life I'm on
I'm on uh blueprint when I wear that
what I'm saying so yeah well I'm not
saying no real quick I uh did my first
Marathon this year my number one album
while I was training for the marathon
I'm hoping he might sign us
most listened to album oh that's crazy
DJ Drama he signed it for me yeah oh you
got drama scientists oh that's fire
right there man I would love to sign
this for you my boy hell yeah that's
under the whole like umbrella of all the
projects the hundreds of projects that's
got to be one of my all-time favorites I
appreciate you I work hard on this man
putting this together
I ain't gonna hold you I gotta draw the
crown
I really got to take a [__]
penmanship class bro everybody that goes
to the show makes me just I need to
learn better because my [__] looks like
[__] man this this album means a lot to
us man we put this together we signed a
monarchy one at the time the old Koch
man shout out Abe
shout out everybody over there man uh
2023 Middle with a pandemic
DJ Shea was alive he basically produced
that album
well was that the last project you guys
worked on together
and uh man [__] just dope can you speak
on the role he's had in Buffalo music
and just music in general because uh
like for me even he put me on the radio
he sat with me he smoked talked and DJ
Shay is the Dr Dre of Buffalo [__]
DJ Shea is
that's what he is he been doing this
longer he's older than us he's been
doing this long before all of us
uh
he's he's wise and he's a talent magnet
you feel what I'm saying so
he been doing this he's a producer he's
a DJ so it like I've been like after
like I said I took over my block when I
met when I dropped 10 to talk one I met
DJ Shay then put out Tana talk too and
took over the city you feel what I'm
saying so that's what he meant that's
that's what kind of person he was like
he was Phil Jackson and even before me
he worked with other artists he worked
with other top-notch artists of the city
uh Griselda just took it further you
guys have your own the buff City [__]
was like the whole studio that was its
own home way before even Griselda right
yeah definitely definitely buff City
Records was like you know you know his
[__] he from the city like heavy in the
city like heavy like like the [__] yeah
I sat on Parkside I sat on there with
him like I bought Hayes from DJ listen
to My Beats and [__] like and we was the
first [__] were like with the super
good weed in the city everybody came to
the studio to get the weed you know what
I'm saying he told me how bad it is out
there so if you got good weed you are
funny I was getting nickel bags you ever
been to Lackawanna South Buffalo yeah
yeah I'm the king of South Buffalo yeah
yeah I wanted to ask you put your rock
on Seneca what's that mean my chicken up
whipping up dropping off and picking up
[__] what my picture's still up on
Seneca
uh my picture up on Seneca is mean that
a painting of me was painted on the side
of a gas station on Seneca of a store
our artist did it man I apologize for I
don't remember the artist's name right
now but
I made I made by The Who
a Ponce he know because it's hanging up
in the store it's not hanging it's not
there no more but it's hanging up in the
shop right right
so uh
but I used to trap on Seneca basically
I'm not gonna make it I can't make it
cinematic I used to trap on Center I
made a lot of money on something yeah so
my pitch is still up on Seneca I'm just
talking [__] A lot of times that's why I
say when I rap I'll be talking to myself
sometimes you know about it right inside
joke to yourself [__] it you leave you
leave fans going what did you mean by
that [__] yeah yes and it sticks 2289
Seneca man means me J-Rock and India
that story from fighter 50 when she on
that song where she say well I had to
flush that was on Seneca Street no [__]
that was on Seneca Street so you know
what I mean so I know all about sending
command shout out to my South Buffalo
[__] let's go south Buffalo Trappers
man when I first met my wife she lives
on Seneca in Princeton move I had all my
[__] in the garbage bag move right in
Marty you're the classic the classic
[__]
I lived off of South Park I lived on
Fredro off of Clinton uh-huh uh man I
lived on I lived
I lived in the Marvel oh damn you're
really over there that's what I'm trying
to tell you wow okay yeah
[Music]
you [__] with snow that's why this fool
can hit bongs like it ain't [__] that
cold weather all day that cold weather
in there right oh he's got this [__]
lungs of a dragon buffalo different
place man Upstate New York is a
different place and the further I travel
and the more I travel the more I realize
that and it's a place to be proud of but
man it's it's a place where you don't
get to see a lot you know you said you
come from a small town you don't get to
[__] see it like
I mean you small town kids y'all got to
get out of your time and make some money
meet some new people try some new things
man that's so important than what we do
yeah when you say snow it's different
like literally we had like 50 people die
last year in the snow like it was like
an actual tragic horrible situation
that's just scary as hell he told me
your doors get stuck open what the [__]
I'm gonna live by the beach talking
about driving with the doors Frozen Open
yeah definitely [__] like that yeah
Justin is just in this blizzard we just
had when people died uh we were we was
riding in that [__] outside I'm saying I
was taking people groceries giving
people rides home oh [__] hell yeah had
my mask on some people ain't even know
it was me yeah that's [__] time like
on some Batman [__] why not yeah man I'm
writing it I got the I got the push I
see on what I'm saying we riding in the
big wagon there we just gave a few
people rides uh help a few people get
groceries and all type of [__] people on
top don't even knows me literally dying
it's Batman freezing in the snow [__]
it doesn't sound like crazy but
literally saving lives it was so bad
people were dying in the street yeah
these young this young girl died I saw
that video donate money to get her get
her body back to her family because she
wasn't from Buffalo she was going to
school in Buffalo that's what I'm saying
so I could just imagine things like that
happen to people locked in the house my
man he in prison doing 11 years I'm
calling checking on his mother get
taking her food and [__] I'm saying
stopping to help people and my my wife
in the car she's like baby don't do that
I'm like man I'm trying to help people
yeah like you she ain't telling me not
to help people but she was like strange
people out here you shouldn't be pulling
up on them trying to help them then I
got back in the house I was watching the
news and they was like yeah don't help
strange people I'm like you're right
because that's what they was doing it
was acting like they need help and then
they was [__] [__] up um
the most evil [__] I ever heard in my
life
[Music]
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about one of our brand new sponsors and
this is board hash and like I said last
time I'm super stoked about these
products because board hash is actually
the facility that they get manufactured
my homie runs that spot one of my close
friends and he's been telling me about
this brand for months and then I finally
saw him and tried them and now they're a
sponsor this one right here is GMO and
inside this box it explains fully what
live resin is so when you get these at
the store you can actually see every
single thing about it so these right
here are their pods there's a little
pods right here the pens so if you're on
Instagram go ahead and follow board hash
let them know the dope as usual podcast
sent you so there we go all three pens
also you guys know from the last time we
talked about board hash they have
Edibles and these are board hash Edibles
so in these there's grape strawberry
orange lemon and blue raspberry a
hundred milligrams for the entire bag 10
milligrams a piece so thank you so much
for supporting the brands that support
us thank you to boardhash have a dope
ass day
hey
it tastes [__] awesome what's up guys
just taking a break to talk about one of
our long time sponsors and this is
manscaped before we even get started let
me give you this information to take
advantage of this deal right now right
now if you go to manscape.com forward
slash Yola or you told Yola at checkout
you're gonna get 20 off of everything
and anything you buy plus free shipping
and they have the perfect package 4.0
luxury and grooming kit the perfect
package is a play on Dick joke manscaped
is right on point but also they are the
leading company on Earth for male
grooming and male grooming kits eight
million customers and 16 million balls
cannot be wrong when it comes to
manscaped lawnmower 4.0 you already know
it's skin safe uh Wireless chargeable
has a light on it's waterproof that
comes in the perfect package 4.0 along
with crop preserver anti-chafing ball
deodorant crop reviver bald toner
disposable shaving mats or the magic mat
plus two free gifts is the travel bag
and the boxers this all comes in the
perfect package 4.0 go ahead and go to
manscape.com right now forward slash
YOLO or like I said use code Yola at
checkout get anything or everything I
just said for 20 off and free shipping
thank you guys so much for supporting
the companies that support us back to
this ridiculous episode
you normally [__] with joints
well not roll Duchess everybody know me
my fans know I roll skinny blunts oh for
real oh so this is a way difference 10
of my shits
mushrooms definitely shrooms yep
I get it I I [__] with the shrooms and
just chill out definitely shrooms
you take a lot though like enough to
everybody get the [__] out of here
trying to lose reality I want to make
sure I take all my watch off put it away
cause I'm gonna wake up without my [__]
on not that much not that much okay so
enough to hang out and be so can you
record on shrimps yeah hell yeah oh okay
okay it's not part of the routine no no
that's not part of the routine it
couldn't be that's not sustainable bro
all right that's not problem you start
making music like your shirt you start
making Pink Floyd [__] [__] going
crazy long ass words science so so when
I'm from from what I hear is I'm like
I'm not I thought I was on a different
level because it's people who don't [__]
with shrooms I'm like no you should try
them oh yeah it's fun but it's like I
know it is another level too yeah yeah
oh yeah there's some nerds out there
yeah no hell no there's some fools like
you ever [__] with this stream like get
the [__] away from me you got [__]
open-toed shoes on get away from me like
I'll be at festivals and there's fools
just be beards like you want some DMT
like no I do a lot of Wii videos like
yeah we got the biggest Wii channel on
YouTube basically on the other side
that's how we do all the wheat all the
warehouse and all the clothes and [__]
so little full like I have a lot of fans
everywhere I go and [__] right right yo
what's up you want I had people offer me
so all kinds of [__] yep because they
see you smoke these type of books they
hear you're talking about this [__] I
talk about psychedelics
oh you ain't seen [__] [__] vape pens
you seen that you wanna I would be so
pissed if my don't ever hand me I'll
hate you forever because people give me
[__] and they don't tell me I'm pissed
there's DMT vape pens there's like a
regular vape pen and you're not even on
the planet in 30 seconds I'd be [__]
pissed that's crazy I [__] with the
shrooms though but I know it's another
level man my boy Tony I got my boy Tony
dinero off the shrooms yeah oh he was
[__] up you get the gummies or the
chocolates or just straight chocolates
or the gummies too straight streams uh
rolling Fruit Roll-Up
a word because once you bite it the
Fruit Roll-Up kind of holds it and you
never taste the shrooms because I eat a
lot so I I don't want to taste all that
[__] dried shrooms like five six grams
of dried shrooms this is like oh an
exercise you say that one time
not not all the time but when I do I do
I I'll go hard okay this [__]
shrooms don't affect him gave him his
first rooms ever he was like so I'm
sober watching my kids took a while to
ramp up took two and a half grams he
didn't do nothing to him damn that's how
they get you because that's what
happened the first time I took him I
really didn't feel it so when I went
back in the next one exactly yeah that's
how I heard people's stories like that
you don't have no stories like that
where you went too hard
I can't tell her here oh okay okay
I remember the first thing I thought was
I looked up at the stars I was like
before you've been there this whole time
the stars were like diamonds just like
no I got it I got it I got it I gotta I
got a story where you know what I'm
saying I'm like okay I probably had too
much of this [__] yeah oh [__] my first
time was 14.
I knew they hit cause I was walking to
get my homie from the park at night you
know you all have that one spot like his
parents don't give a [__] let's get
[__] up in the garage and then they
I'd walk by a tree and I heard
but I looked up and the [__] was
growing and said the sky damn and I
stared at him by the time I look forward
my homies were [__] three four blocks
ahead of me they're all [__] up too so
they weren't looking for me but I
realized I had been staring here for two
to three minutes straight right that's
the thing I've never seen nothing
visually when you do you're gonna
[__] lose your mind because it's so
no no no it's so what I do is seven
grams damn that's a first that is a
first a seven grams and then I go in the
dark pitch black because you can't see
anything so everything you think you see
because it's like close your eyes you
can imagine it's the same thing because
it's black right right
so everything you see is like it's Vivid
there was other P like I flew around my
neighborhood it was [__] nuts I have
a whole long snow I looked down I saw my
own body in my house
I could see myself on my bed my [__]
wife's next to me she's she's the same
amount as I do and she was [__] up
six hours next to she has a whole other
experience I'm sitting there I can feel
a sweat and like hour four I'm like
where the [__] am I but in the pitch
black bro you don't know what's your
body's doing that's what my boy was like
we was looking at a picture he was like
so that picture is not moving I'm like
he's like you meant to tell me you don't
see his pictures trying to get yes they
start yeah I like the waves though yeah
there's a picture with water it was a
picture
it looks like when the ground turns to
waves that's my [__] because that you
don't know how to step I love that I
only had like one good maybe I didn't
get that I didn't get to that level yet
you will please
calling me four in the morning nine
minute face face time him just yeah see
what if we just opened up the
Psychedelic part of your career real man
I'm telling you getting into rocking
[__] for the next half your career big
shrooms Family Man BSF
where's the merch where's the [__]
Merchant I got a question yeah go for it
how did Benny times the Buffalo Bills
happen
because going on with their [__]
website we got the merch line we got the
official Anthem we got the uh
documentary the official Anthem he did
the mafia Anthem oh I did on the [__]
bills [__] right him on after the video
in the locker room
real [__] on the field hills.com go get
your [__] Benny merch because they
you guys got a [__] NFL team in a
small small town that's [__] nuts you
guys are like Pittsburgh right isn't
that the same thing I think Pittsburgh
is a little bit bigger but yeah
Pittsburgh these other cities don't have
this reputation of being so goddamn
hopeless that's the difference about
Buffalo Buffalo's got this Perpetual
gray cloud that people just know about
kind of like Detroit but even more like
damn like it's like it's like it's the
Super Bowl it's like [__] like that
affects the people that's that's
in the city
you know what I'm saying no it does but
what I mean is like it make us stronger
yeah it don't it don't [__] us up and
make us stronger it's [__] up people
from every city but they make us
stronger yeah that's where the our Ted
Talk was called uh definition of a
hustler that's where that comes from we
talked about the mentality of what it
takes to make it happen basically it's
like damn I'm up against the impossible
but I like that right you're gonna fight
like the underdog you know the underdog
yeah it's gonna take 10 20 years I'm
signing up for that but I'm gonna make
it though that's
what it takes to that's how you got a
thing full for longevity too like you
said you said well M M's that's when you
guys got big like you're like just
[__] been 20 years you've been
crushing it exactly it's a different
story like I said it's it's underground
and then now it should know it's
independent slash
underground yes those are years I was
underground and then I grew to
Independent you know what I'm saying
sorry Buffalo Bills how did that happen
oh Tony dinero man my boy Tony dinero he
made a connection uh on my guy Rob uh
the Bill's familiar with us they know
what he's familiar with us we know what
they do it we know they know we do the
merchant [__]
what else
uh shout out and I know she haven't been
feeling well but I did an interview with
her so
I'm pretty sure you know what I'm saying
you know she owns the team with her
husband
to take it from having a goddamn FBI
cases and [__] to being the
representative of the bills to Byron
Brown declaring [__] Conrad the
machine day in Buffalo like
you know it's not feel like it's insane
you know that's the craziest [__] in the
world yeah I mean that's the craziest
[__] in the world you know [__]
it's a whole new life you know what I
mean so that's why everybody that's why
everybody around you can't understand it
because they're not in your shoes but
this is literally a whole new life when
you come from that and you come from
that the street [__] the real in tune
with it though I'm saying not glorifying
enough but just drawing Spectrum because
being really in it you know what I'm
saying having three felonies or being
through those raids and
marrying a girl who who was with me
through all of that you know what I'm
saying so it's like
it's a different life to to see this
[__] and I'm happy for everybody I'm
happy for Conway I'm happy for West Side
gun
I mean this [__] is nuts it's crazy but
that's why it comes with responsibility
too so definitely like you said guide
the Next Generation that's something
good Next Generation it's gonna be
people from Buffalo who gonna run
further than Iran well my my dad is in
the uh Buffalo Music Hall of Fame it's
one of the songs right here
damn that's done yeah he passed away I
got to accept his uh his induction in
the Hall of Fame and show oh man you
know what that's why I gotta make it in
there I'm saying I'm a donator I'm gonna
give a a gold plaque to them from Johnny
P's caddy um
that's what I said already I said I got
to give one of these to the museum
yeah just to solidify like I'm from a
small town we had an artist on here his
name is GB uh Ghetto Boys uh Mexican
artist [__] dope he's from my town he
just got a
he doesn't so much get he used to be
I grew up in the [__] ghetto he's the
[__] I would avoid he's like I
ain't trying to get shot I don't want to
hang out I'm selling weed I don't give a
[__] but now he's kind of like cleans up
a park the park I used to [__] chill
at where all the gangbangers were and I
knew just play football over there and
don't talk to them right right you know
what I'm saying he just got the award
from the a city for
humanitarian or some crazy [__] I know
you're like how the [__] that happened
no it's I like I love it being from the
kid that used to wear the mask running
around shooting [__] to hey you
accept an award in the suit you know
what I mean but you guys are doing your
thing and you're obviously your own
merch but it is wild that an NFL team is
partnering with you guys and you guys
are from the [__] City and I know
you're you're back when you you were
doing your [__] shopping [__] whatever
you would never imagine I'm going to be
on the field yeah doing my doing my
music hell no hell no man definitely
it's a blessing it's a blessing we know
we real Bills fans I'm saying we're real
Bill's face man we we
before all of this [__] you remember
each of the four Super Bowls as a child
it was traumatic I remember that even
before they were good you know what I'm
saying we was riding with them so to be
a part of this is a blessing to
represent the side of the city I do
you know real Noble real Noble gangster
Robin Hood [__] man for the people for
the people man what are you making Josh
Allen right now
and I love Josh you just got to get
settled the Bill's never been a first
half team a beginning of the Season team
since we got Josh I'm saying he always
he always gotta get a game or two to
figure it out so I love Josh man
everybody from Buffalo is a [__] fan
you just broke it down he his wife will
not so he's got to sit back in the
pocket I swear to God everybody from
Buffalo is a die-hard commentator and
[__] no you guys really know your [__]
it's a football town like you said
there's nothing but Drinking Breaking
[__] tables going to work like
there's not I get it you guys are just
blue collar Town definitely because I
just saw today they posted they're
having the raffle for people to be able
to start like I don't know what stage
you're opening the [__] weed store as
it is but some big important stage of
being that I experienced that out when I
first moved out here 10 years ago I
rolled out in Orange County and I'm just
so excited for Buffalo because it's
about to do the same [__] right and you
know do you have any plans on like being
at the Forefront of that for the time
it's funny you asked
man basically
uh
we just closed on the farm you know what
I'm saying like a big ass Farm I was
wondering what that was about out there
yes yes an Upstate New York and I'm
saying me me and my guys you know I'm
saying an investment group uh I'm
telling we're gonna we when we when
everything is done to finalize because
it's a big it takes forever exactly and
it's something huge going on so as soon
as it uh finalizes man we're gonna run
around we're gonna talk about it and
it's gonna be crazy and I'm saying it's
gonna be like definitely going to be the
biggest [__] in Upstate New York
definitely you know what I'm saying it's
gonna have like multiple locations it's
gonna be it's gonna be different things
like from top to bottom from growing a
product to to packaging it to to be in
the stores where you can do everything
right even if people got their own
businesses there they can just deal with
us they wouldn't have to you know I'm
saying we yeah a bunch of [__] going on
so much opportunity right now it's
exciting I know you know what you're
getting into but that that's like a
four generational wealth type of thing
exactly that's different that's the
reason that's the reason of it you know
what I'm saying man
[Music]
you know what's crazy it's just
like
I was I was on my way home right from
from New York City I was on my way home
to Buffalo I pulled up I was at the
hotel and I seen like these rich dudes
coming out the restaurant at the hotel
and they was going upstairs I I couldn't
tell they were going upstairs to the
rooftop it was a rooftop party at the
top of the hotel I was gonna end up
going there too but I was just had to go
freshen up and [__]
so uh
uh they recognized who I was so we
chopped it for a second and then it was
like take some pics I'm like I'm gonna
come change my [__] and I'm gonna get up
there I just drove six hours from New
York City
and then I went up there and that's what
I was chopping it up with him I'm saying
and they offered me a percentage at a
company they come and they buying it
that's how this worked that's how this
was work I haven't I didn't have to put
in a dollar I didn't have to do nothing
and shout out to uh my boy Jimmy you
know what I'm saying
uh shout out my boy Jay shout out Surge
and everybody else but gave me a
percentage of that [__] and keep me
posted on everything from
closing from uh
helping find buildings everything man so
just similar to what's my place at the
right time man yeah I just know the
exact same thing you said generational
wealth type of [__] and just want to
Humbug it's all for me it's crazy that's
like not even my passion it's just it's
just an actual business I love [__]
weed but I'm not growing it yeah man I
got the time for that James Johnson used
to play for the heat man I'm saying
shout out to him man that's who you're
messing with though um and some other
guys too and some other guys too but
definitely though so that just that's
just a crazy story right there I mean
just out of nowhere just met those guys
man these dudes as rich as [__]
Buffalo I've seen them like what these
what's these dudes doing in Buffalo oh
one of those yeah but it was like come
kick it with us upstairs because you
don't see nice cars like at least when I
lived there I had never seen a Bentley I
had never seen a Rolls-Royce or you know
like a regular Benz is a nice car
[__] Tesla's a nice car you know like
so somebody's like in some expensive
[__] they [__] stand out for real
[__] that's why I was riding around in
that [__] my drop I had to drop
top Benz and buffalo riding around for
about a month in that [__] a drop top
in the in the cold it wasn't cold I'm
sorry I have no idea about how cold it
is
I don't know it was a summertime all
right so it gets warm I might get 90
sometimes at that [__] yeah yeah I'm
sorry everything I ever see is like damn
it looks [__] frozen over there right
right that's a fact but it get it get
nice out there too again they get hot
out that [__] too you know what I'm
saying so you got any plans on moving or
you're gonna I live in Atlanta oh you do
yeah I still got a uh Buffalo but I live
in Atlanta nice what I'm saying is that
for music for word is that why you're
out there it's for music work it's for
family but it's for family first you
know what I'm saying
the house is out there for the prices
make me want to leave California forever
exactly I used to go to school down
there I used to live back down there in
the 90s in Atlanta yeah so my family
been living down there oh no [__] like
what what grade we what grades you go
out there I was in eighth grade
yeah just eighth grade and did you get
kicked out and have to go out there is
that why
when I got kicked out of school I had to
go back to Buffalo that's what happened
oh okay they say I got kicked up
same [__] but I lost all my people I saw
weed too because people smoke weed every
day if you don't answer one [__] time
it might be over so that's why selling
is great but it's also like don't miss
your phone call like you don't go out of
town Christmas you better be [__]
ready to sell some weed that's why the
Trap [__] can't leave can't go nowhere
they can't go nowhere because they never
went nowhere getting rich as a [__] go
nowhere to save food cause you can't
[__] leave nowhere real [__] I feel
you Dude I go to Santa Cruz buy CDs and
come back cause I gotta be back I stash
20s and tens on certain parts of my
house outside and the couch in the back
nobody ever [__] burned me dude I did
[__] like that too I did that [__] like
that too
I did [__] like that too when I had to
leave one time not not go out of town
when I had to leave for a couple hours I
was trapping in the Trap I stashed 20s
and I stash 40s and I stash grams and
I'm saying because I knew people be
calling me so I'm like yo huh pull up
I would make them bring me the money
first though oh you are straight you
can't leave it in the mailbox you can't
trust dope fiends you don't sell the
weeds okay yeah
but also it's like take one 40 sack
[__] leave the re that's even
sketchy no real [__] that's a fact I
love this yeah you can bring me the
money I used to make him bring me the
money now I tell them where the dope was
at for real oh damn that's a real drugs
dealership I just like you know my house
but you smoke me that I got burnt before
though I still got burned before trying
to be nice and then it didn't make him
bring me the money
oh yeah they're not coming I never it
was for 40 Rock once it's open it's over
40. I always heard about that matter of
fact it was for 240s 80. ugh yeah you
know that was [__] up every dollar
hurt back then every dollar hurt back
then hell yeah it's it's it's does it
kind of make you smile though now
sometimes like 15 water bottle [__]
showcase okay it's okay it's different I
know I used to used to be [__] up used
to be poor and I used to and I you know
what you know what coming from that type
of life is so that's why you that's why
you gotta you gotta grind it and get to
see a different level with this [__] so
you know you were being petty back then
you was thinking small back then yeah so
it's good to reach the other level so
you could tell yourself like what the
[__] was I doing we said every [__]
what were we doing back when the [__]
was I doing dude I [__] feel you
completely I used to stress about I'm
paying for how much on this like bro
that is a [__] haircut what are you
stressing on but back when you're
selling sags and reading up on QPS and
halves and then then I got into packs
like you said every [__] dollar
really meant something my rent was only
600 and I was still like all right I
gotta hurry up get that [__] hell yeah
you know that so like when you when you
ran up or you know you're a trap [__]
you buying a a four and a half were you
buying a nine
every few hundred dollars count every
few hundred dollars count what I'm
saying so on the way to that few hundred
dollars is like an 80 piece gone you
know what's going on you know what I'm
saying so hell yeah I remember that life
like it was yesterday yeah it sounded
like you're waking up in the morning
bagging up bundles
with a mask on sometimes without a mask
on
fentanyl where nobody knew knew about
that [__]
you know I'm saying and and then even
think about this [__] just reminding me
right now I'm like what the [__] was I
doing like I was 30 years old three-time
felon selling dope hand in hand oh damn
selling dope
that's crazy it's insane
I might as well been playing in a
[__] highway yeah what was going
through your mind were you desperate
were you hard-headed were you not well I
didn't care just no other option
I'm gonna be honest with you
what what was going through my mind was
this is this is what I always
done
you know what I'm saying so to be honest
with you I already accepted the
consequence of whatever happened
and that and just saying that just
reminds me like what the [__] was I
doing
but I really accepted the consequence
I really woke up looked at my girl every
day thinking like I might have to leave
this [__] I'm saying it's like [__]
gonna get ugly I'm saying it how in love
we were at that time thinking like man
this you know what I'm saying just
looking at my daughter
even picking her up from school
like this real [__] looking in her face
but these are I'm just being honest with
you it's not like this is not like every
every every every [__] know who who who
playing that game at that level no and
I'm not the only one so [__] watching
is going no it's not nothing that's
harping on my brain all day every day
these is like quick thoughts that happen
yeah dude throughout my day as you leave
the house always as I'm doing some [__]
or you know I'm saying as I'm just like
yo I'll be right back but I know what
I'm gonna go do and I'm saying knowing
what what might be on the other end of
that door or that phone call
you understand so it wasn't like nothing
and then I think about that then I think
about life I'm about to get this money
always overtook it though you know just
just what we did because
we had better we had better
opportunities but
to me and I can't speak for nobody else
I feel like I have better opportunities
but they weren't
they weren't right in front of me you
know what I'm saying I went what was
right in front of me I'm from a block
where everybody did that well I know a
lot of people are going to say that but
like my in my city my block was known
for that at the time you know what I'm
saying it was it was known for that
it was like what people came from the
different parts of the city to come to
my block for I'm saying so
[Music]
even though I might even I might not
have been involved in it at that point
in time
but it was the first it was the culture
of my neighborhood so
it was in my blood to wanna
be a trap or to wanna
you know some [__] graduating the [__] I
mean I'm not gonna say it's dumb [__]
but I'ma just say it's like the mindset
is dumb [__] not the culture of the hood
because it gave me a sense of something
to be proud about anything that gives
you something to be proud about
that's dope give you confidence a young
black kid from the hood and I was proud
to be from my neighborhood because I
stood for something but anyway
I don't think it's dumb [__] I just
think that
you know we don't exercise our options
man when we come from the ghetto we
don't we don't exercise our options
that's why you got a bunch of
[__]
trying to teach [__] real estate
because they like it's other [__] to do
than dope dealing and rapping and
playing ball [__] you see them [__]
getting rich off real estate you know
what I'm saying so so much other things
to do but you know everybody want to be
cool everybody want to be in the streets
because that's the easiest thing to do
when you grow up from the hood when you
in the hood it's two things that you're
gonna get your respect of when you first
come up
and as a dope dealer
not dope Dylan getting money
or swinging that gun
but those are the easiest things
swinging a gun is easier than getting
the money so that's why that's the
that's why everybody doing it because
it's easier to get the money I mean
because it's harder to get the money
so other dudes get the money but you
know you know this [__] Wicked I'm
saying but for me in my head that's
what's going through in my head that
time at those times but I can't believe
I was doing that [__] man I can't
believe that [__]
I got homies doing time 22 years life 11
years what was how deep were you in
music at that point
I was I was the hottest [__] I was I was
you know I'm saying I already was a
legend in the city damn still doing all
the time in the studio all the time I'm
still doing
I was still doing a BSF business and I'm
saying black soprano family was people
coming to tell it it was people coming
to me 10 years ago telling me to stop
wearing BSF shirts because it's hot the
fed's looking at you yeah it was people
like calling my phone having private
conversations or people reaching out to
other people telling me that like I'm
saying like yo I mean I'll let you go
such and such
I mean it was [__] like that going on
when I was 30 years old going hand in
hand with this [__] rapping and doing
[__] like I got a video I got a video
that I took down
and yeah people are gonna go watch this
[__] I've been trying to get this [__]
taken down off YouTube It's called my
stove please turn up my stove
and and that's on Seneca and the house
is on Seneca and we in there doing the
most I got India in there my wife now
and she in there dancing she got the
booty shorts on and all type of [__] we
are wildling in that mother we act like
we cooking dope in a Papa we was in the
real spot where we was doing business
out of shot that video amongst all of
that going on yeah
crazy you're [__] you're risking that
[__]
nah when you when you make the move the
video about that you're gonna look back
oh what the [__] was I thinking I think
the same [__] though like you're really
not making that much money but driving
50 packs but you're risking a lot man I
got some crate I got some crazy stories
man about that about that [__] man I
wonder like I have I honestly I haven't
I haven't I haven't done this [__]
in at least 10 years
a long time
but I want to be able to tell these
stories man outside the rap it's crazy
[__] man just to let you know like where
the [__] the [__] mind was at
but if you apply that dumb [__]
to this
you would be the best Hustler ever in
the world
if you apply that negative you know what
I'm saying to this [__] you'll be the
best hustle in the world
I just like because when people ask me
the same [__] you did it was helmet 10
years and you went
because you remember he remembered
exactly the date and [__] people always
ask me to go
11 years ago because it's always
something you got to remember like this
is on camera you better shut the [__] up
that's why I don't even talk about
certain things not really sure you never
know what these people these these these
authorities these law enforcement
authorities is out here they they gun
hole they want to use the lyrics they
want to use the lifestyle for sure they
wanted they wanted they want to go for
easy targets uh
I mean they want to go for the
low-hanging fruit for a rapper somebody
like that who who's might be riding
around with a gun to protect themselves
who might be involved in
public beefs and [__] like that so you
know they latch on through [__] like
that so you got to be careful man you
know what I'm saying is it bad like I
know when I lived in Buffalo the cops
are up in your [__] life like way
differently it's not bad it's not bad I
was uh
it's not bad for me man they you know
what I'm gonna be honest with you
it's 50 50. they do be on my eyes back
they got to really think about that one
huh because I didn't want to because I
didn't want to you know I mean because I
thought about the good [__] first so
that's good though different mentality
and I thought about the other [__] now
they do be on my ass it's like you
notice that I never perform like it's a
it's a it's a club there that I never
performed in because
Conway performer West Side gun
performing and I performing it with them
and I had sold out shows in other parts
of the city but not there because they
don't let me book there you know what
I'm saying I don't know why maybe they
had their reasons why you know what I
mean but it's a lot of [__] like that
that going with me you know I'm saying
that they be on certain [__] with me in
Buffalo
but there's other good [__] too they put
me over the other day when a couple
months ago
and they uh they searched my car they
put me in the back and everything and
then he told me I had a warrant
but I'm like I don't got no [__]
warrant and I know I don't I kind of
like blacked out on him and then he was
like I didn't say I was was going to
take you I'm thinking like them since
when y'all don't take people for
warrants because Buffalo police taking
you if you got a warrant
but [__] ain't take me so you looked out
for me so I respect that and then bro I
took care of it I flew out here from I
flew I flew out here and landed in
Buffalo I took a red eye landed off the
plane jumped in my Whip and then went
right to court took care of it
about a week later and then about
another two weeks later I'm just I'm
just kicking it just out I'm out kicking
in the Buffalo so
this guy like yo I [__] with your music
I like your [__] he had a suit on and
[__] I'm like yo appreciate you some in
this love he was like man you got a
warrant I'm a Buffalo police officer
shut the [__] up that's something so
blow Johnny Depp [__] right there
let's go to the bathroom and come back
and your knife's gone what the [__] was
that yo I'm a big fan get in the [__]
car now he didn't take he did he didn't
take me he was just we was at a party we
was out at a club
he was in plain clothes and he just let
me know like that's what I do you got a
warrant you might want to get that taken
care of but I'm like I went last week
just took care of we gotta update update
your [__] oh man I thought you meant
this is something for something else
petty [__] I ever [__] heard of nah
[__] no I don't be I don't be into [__]
and I'm saying I don't be into [__] yo
and one time I met this there's one cop
two up there because I'm telling you
because when they see me and they'd be
in they playing clothes they say [__] to
me because they honestly a lot of them
are fans of hip-hop
I'm saying and I am Billy the [__]
butcher so I don't I don't I don't I'm
not mad at it I love it but that's what
he said to me he was like yo
he was like what the [__] he said to me
he was like man it's good that you got
everything you're going on man you need
you should just switch everything legit
and I'm like what that's what I did do
real [__] that's crazy right what's he
confused about I don't know
and I'm like I'm like yo that's crazy
that's some that's some crazy [__] to
say it's like I don't know what they be
talking about down there he's just
basically gonna talk too still yeah he's
like damn this [__] just dropped this
[__] why
I don't know what the [__] they got
going on down there that's funny they
obviously don't got YouTube yeah music
or I don't know the Instagram I don't
know what they don't got but [__] yeah
things are different now all this makes
the whole Bill's deal all this [__] with
the [__] Byron Brown even more
relevant and more just you guys crossed
over it's yeah yeah yeah man and Marty's
constantly constantly just talking about
you guys doing man we appreciate Marty
man is he holding it down too he's a
buffalo representative
you know what I'm saying yeah and we
appreciate that too man one thing about
Buffalo people we're going to chew we're
going to eat no matter what you're not
going to chew so shout out to the city
everything amen we love y'all one last
fun fact you know who David gotten is
toughest man on Earth uh he went on
Rogan and became Super Famous he's like
uh Navy SEAL all that type of first
black Navy SEAL right but he's like uh
ultra marathon runner all those super
high endurance Guinness World Record
[__] but you know Skateland yeah
his family owns it he grew up oh that's
cleaning the floors and [__] that's
crazy
yeah right and he became uh Delavan or
some [__]
yeah it was like it was famous in the
seventh and like Rick James it was
famous when we was growing up in the 90s
too man we went to that [__] crazy but
yeah he's like he's another one out of
Buffalo it's super Lex Luger hmm what do
you mean Alexa Luger out of Buffalo you
ain't know that no Lex Luger the
producer nah the wrestler oh
right right you know that right right he
looks Luger I'm saying that's a good one
I just saw the toy in my head the little
the rubber ones
like see I didn't I wasn't I wrestling I
went back to like Waka Flocka beats and
[__] in my head and he's like you like
the [__] producer
no David Gaga is the toughest man on
Earth he has the pull-up most pull-ups
in 19 hours world record he's one of
them [__] uh what's his name again
David Goggins David God he is the he's a
he's a machine bro if you need something
to listen to his books are awesome he
talks about crazy ass stories watch
y'all put them together where can they
find your uh like your music your
current music oh you already know
Spotify Apple music title go to title
find my [__] y'all know what it is man
YouTube anywhere you at Amazon but go to
title and it's get Benny on Instagram
right get Benny on Instagram uh is get
Benny on Twitter
it's Benny the butcher in real life
Jeremy pinnick is my government name you
could Google it
I'm saying call me what you want to call
me baby we appreciate you man uh this is
this is it we're [__] hyped thank you
for being here thank you I'm [__]
hype you smoke that whole joint no one
ever [__] smokes the whole joy and
they leave it there for the whole
[__] show I promise you I'm smoking
we appreciate you thank you very much
for being appreciate y'all it was a
pleasure man appreciate you I know our
fans are hyped guys it's been the Betty
the butcher episode this is Marty
yeah yeah
I'm actually a [__] high [__]
[Music]
perfect